c'est non non il est temps pour nous
d'écouter la plaie de pardon le
réquisitoire
déjà il procureur des proches je vais je
voulais dormir un peu mais le temps
passe et bien monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les jurés public
chéri avant d'aborder le fond même de
mon réquisitoire j'aimerais être tout de
même vous dire combien il est pénible
pour un homme d'avoir un requérir contre
l'un de ses semblables aussi abjecte
soit il
c'est une tâche rude et éprouvante mais
je l'assumerai jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle
par devoir envers la république et pour
les trois bris qui tombent tous les mois
passaient pas l'administrateur vous en a
pas parlé dernièrement
non je dirais que je l'évité ils vont en
parler cela dit messieurs les jurés au
cas où vous auriez quelque indulgence
envers l'accusé calvi ici présent c'est
vraiment trois bris bon qu'est ce que tu
as me tente bon se gausse vianne
monsieur le président n'en déplaise à
son avocat flux est de type quasiment
d'or africain ali zardari l'accusé qui a
des notes
j'ai noté que je me défende tout à
l'heure l'accusé calvi ne mérite à aucun
titre
la clémence de la société d autres d
autres 2 est composé de l'associé de la
société voyez cette phase gorgé de
veulerie rédhibitoire et en messieurs
les jurés
on y lit la dégénérescence alcoolique la
plus infamante la gnôle l'agneau et non
pas seulement le pinard et la vraie
maîtresse de ce débris humains
car gérard calvi de son vrai nom gérard
calva gérard calvi est marqué par la
gnôle d'ailleurs il est allé à l'école
rue des batignolles s'est fait partie
des branquignols il a fréquenté marcel
pagnol
il a même joué du piano avec arthur
rouby style
sans doute l'accusé aurait il pu réussir
une carrière musicale
car grand et s aidant je le reconnais
mais s'il fallait choisir ou boire ou
jouer du piano
j'ai un truc je fous le lead dans le
piano à queue tu fais un truc je suis
maintenant s'il vous plaît ou boire ou
jouer du piano voix rauque ont posé
calvi qu'elle va a choisi il a choisi de
boire quand il s'agissait de jouer il
était introuvable
et c'est pas par hasard qu'ils aient eu
le premier prix de fugue en 1942 il
dépensé tout l'argent de ces pauvres
parents au bistrot vous ne pouvez pas
nier verser plus d'argent messieurs les
jurés calvi pillaient les troncs des
églises
il vous est impossible denier du culte
toute cette vie de débauche
que reste-t-il du gunu du cul du comment
peut-on composé du cul du dirigeant
parodiant le statique
le syndic du boulevard voltaire
amplement plus tôt il a dit a certes ce
n'est pas mozart qui aurait composé du
but ce n'est pas de bussy qui aurait
composé du cul du ce n'est pas francis
lopez qui aurait composé du culte façon
il connaît de la gamme jusqu'à mieux
passé mais il ya plus grave
interrogé hier par notre assesseurs la
troublante marina pas d'agression dans
interrogé par marina donc le sieur calvi
calva a déclaré je cite ce que
j'aimerais détruire ces l'imbécillité
vous avez dit ça mais j'en ai marre
gentiment non non il a dit sur un ton
très sec et messieurs les jurés là c'est
grave parce que la voilà la vraie
subversion car s'il est vrai que le plus
court chemin de la barbarie à la
décadence passe par la civilisation
il est aussi vrai que sans les imbéciles
la civilisation siefridt comme à
bruxelles notamment essilor est refusé
anne injures racistes s'il vous plaît si
l'on détruise est la deuxième fait
monsieur calvi qui rentreraient le
week-end le dimanche entre six et huit
par la même autoroute qui lierait la
biographie denise fabre qui siègeraient
au palais bourbon on irait applaudir
dalida mireille président de la
république qu'il irait à la guerre qui
écouterait mon réquisitoire la seule la
b6 lité de l'homme le plus sûr garant de
la civilisation monsieur calvi même les
animaux ont besoin de notre imbécillité
comme le dit si justement frédéric dard
plus le maître et qu'on plus le chien
est fidèle j'en ai terminé monsieur le
président qui demande la peine de mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fait non non